love joy yeah hang in there I do I have
cataplexy I pass out anytime I feel
strong emotions yes
in my case it's mainly joy don't you
want to fall in love I need to be
careful I need someone I can picture in
sweatpants Friday I have yarn making
class we're about to take on alpaca did
I get you to talk about the yarn nope
I'm Francesca by the way why do I keep
attracting and I have no future unless
it's the other way around
some sort of pheromone and here drink I
don't want to do this I can't do it if
you're looking for a boyfriend eat my
brother wait what you going out with
Francesca she's big laugher I don't
think I'm that funny but funny I like
you didn't hear her a minimun offer I
couldn't refuse
that's Brenda what's eventually him
right
don't know compression what they were
versus you think so I'm happy just
sucking it up with Francesca she's
everything I've ever voided drawn are
like a moth well that I'm cut out for
this you know don't just throw away so
that we never see her again we you
there's something really wrong with you
yeah not that you
[Music]
gotta stick your neck out sometimes life
will pass you right by you can't keep
yourself from loving something just
because you're afraid you're gonna lose
them this is incredibly depressing yeah
[Music]
we something funny yeah Oni this one is
called where did my sweet grandma go Oh
you